et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
emmanuelle wargon bonjour bonjour ou
coup d'être avec nous et délégué chargé
du logement on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par julien lécuyer
de la voix du nord bonjour julien
bonjour oriane madame ministre bonjour
et on commence donc par l'actualité et
c'est toujours la crise sanitaire on
attend olivier verrons ce soir à 18
heures qui a priori ne devrait pas
annoncer de mesures restrictives vous
allez nous le confirme et un rien peut
faire basculer la situation a dit hier
gabriel attal à l'issue du conseil de
défense est ce que ça veut dire que le
gouvernement redoute un relâchement des
français ça veut dire que pour l'instant
nos mesures de gestion de la crise
sanitaire fonctionne on est sur un
plateau élevé mais on est dans une forme
de stabilité
ça veut surtout dire que chacun d'entre
nous doit continuer à respecter les
gestes barrières les mesures du type
couvre-feu c'est important parce que
c'est ça qui nous permet de rester dans
cette situation là et de ne pas avoir à
restreindre plus nos libertés les
épidémiologistes restent très alarmiste
sur la situation en mars compte tenu de
la de la progression du variant on est
toujours dans la philosophie au
gouvernement de passer par ce qu'on
nomme le trou de souris
notre objectif c'est d'abord un objectif
sanitaire de protection de la santé de
la population et en respectant cet
objectif sanitaire de trouver la voie de
passage qui nous permet de continuer à
vivre de continuer à notre économie de
fonctionner à chacun d'entre nous de
mener la vie la plus normale possible
pendant cette période de virus c'est
cette voie de passage qui ce fameux trou
de souris cette voie qui est étroite
mais qui existent et qui pour l'instant
fonctionne plutôt bien
on pourrait quand même à penser à des
mesures territoriales quand même pour
contrer certaines émergence je pense
notamment à ma région à dunkerque qui
est particulièrement touché par le
variant anglais alors on n'exclut
absolument rien vous le savez nous avons
déjà pris dans la phase précédente dans
la phase précédente des mesures
territorialisée avec des heures
différentes sur l'application de
certaines mesures
donc ça n'est pas du tout exclu et de
toute façon la situation est réévaluée
et quasiment au quotidien
mais ça veut dire qu'il pourrait y avoir
des annonces de mesures territorialise
olivier vers en fait une conférence de
presse en général chaque semaine il ya
des annonces régulièrement et donc on va
voir ce qui se passe ce soir
allez on va parler de vos dossiers sont
nombreux à emmanuelle wargon va
commencer par la construction de
logements y aurait une nouvelle
réglementation environnementale qui va
s'appliquer à tous les logements neufs
est ce que vous pouvez nous dire en quoi
elle va consister
oui bien sûr moi je suis très fier que
cette réglementation environnementale
arrive c'est une réglementation qui va
nous aider à ce qu'il y ait moins
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
moins de carbone dans la construction et
dans le bâtiment en général
elle va permettre d'avoir des exigences
plus fortes sur la consommation
d'énergie donc d'électricité de gaz de
toutes les formes d'énergie quand on
chauffe un bâtiment un logement avec une
mise meilleure isolation donc besoin de
moins d'énergie
elle va nous permettre d'accélérer la
sortie des énergies fossiles dans le
bâtiment pourra voir voilà pourra
atteindre notre trajectoire de
décarbonation et puis et c'est une
grande innovation puis j'ai moi même un
bon c'est quoi l'objectif exactement je
finis juste surveillé après je réponds à
la question est donc une consommation
plus faible des bâtiments et puis pour
la première fois on s'intéresse au bilan
carbone de la construction c'est-à-dire
du process de construction lui-même et
des matériaux et ça c'est une innovation
l'objectif c'est d'atteindre les
engagements que nous avons pris pour
l'accord de paris qui sont transcrits
dans une stratégie nationale s'appelle
la stratégie nationale bas carbone
elle prévoit qu'on réduise les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre des bâtiments et
cette réglementation qui s'applique aux
neuf le neuf c'est 1% du parc de
logements chaque année
donc cette réglementation va nous aider
parce que tous les bâtiments neufs qu'on
va construire à partir de l'entrée en
vigueur l'année prochaine seront plus
économes en énergie et mettront moins de
carbone est donc l'objectif
l'objectif chiffré hier j'entends
l'objectif chiffré c'est de réduire de
35 % les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre du secteur de la construction ce
qui fait environ 28 millions de tonnes
de l'origine dès 2030 2030 à moi juste
sur l'entrée en application vous dites
l'année prochaine ça veut dire que c'est
à décaler l'entrée en négociation nous
avons beaucoup consulté concertée
discuté dans cette dernière phase nous
avions présenté les grandes orientations
avec barbara pont pilier en novembre
et suite à ses discussions avec tous les
professionnels
nous avons décidé j'ai décidé de décaler
la date d'application au 1er janvier
2022 pour que chaque filière et le temps
de se préparer dans de bonnes conditions
vous rencontrez un tout à l'heure en
visioconférence les acteurs de la de la
construction on a senti quand même chez
ed des inquiétudes et notamment
concernant la le coût de la construction
liées justement à la nouvelle
réglementation environnementale
comment vous comptez les rassurer
d'abord c'est normal que des questions
se posent
on change de réglementation sur la
construction des bâtiments tous les dix
ans et là on fait un saut qualitatif
vraiment très important on aura la
réglementation l'une des réglementations
les plus ambitieuses d'europe
ensuite les calculs de surcoûts ont été
faits on a essayé de quantifier avec les
différentes filières professionnelles si
ça allait renchérir le coût de la
construction on est maintenant en
hypothèse entre 3 et 5% au maximum de
surcoût potentiel et nous avons
l'expérience de la dernière
réglementation elle date de 2012
il y avait une hypothèse de surcoût
entre 10 et 15% qui ne s'est pas
réalisée en fait y'a pas eu de surcoûts
après 2000 tous donc il ya aussi
beaucoup d'innovations dans les filières
beaucoup d'innovations dans les
processus de construction et donc là le
plus probable c'est que les filières
s'adapte et que finalement le coût de la
construction reste mais non vous ne
craignez pas tout de même que ces
surcoûts malfato qui va exister dans
tous les cas c'est assez logique ne se
répercute pas sur une fine et les prix
de l'immobilier en eux mêmes non je
crois qu'ils on a la possibilité
d'absorber dans la filière dans la somme
du prix du foncier du prix de la
construction
un prix qui reste maîtrisée évidemment
pour les opérations de type logement
social de toute façon le prix de sortie
et maîtrisée par ailleurs le marché
immobilier et moi à la hausse en ce
moment que dans les périodes précédant
donc je pense que l'équation est plutôt
favorable à ce qu'on ait un maintien des
prix s qui aura des exceptions où tout
le monde sera logé à la même enseigne
pour certaines constructions
particulière vous dit tu auras dur à
certaines exceptions il n'y a pas
d'exception mais par contre tout ceci
est très phase et dans le temps c'est à
dire tous ne s'applique pas brutalement
au même moment
certaines dates ne sont pas les mêmes
pour les maisons individuelles
elle est pour les immeubles collectifs
et nous avons des paliers qui permettent
au secteur de la construction de
progresser étape par étape donc une
première partie de la réglementation
rentrer en vigueur au 1er janvier
prochain
l'horaire quel type de construction pour
la réduction de consommation de 30% des
bâtiments ça c'est dès janvier prochain
pour les maisons individuelles la sortie
du gaz commence dès janvier prochain
avec des mesures de transition pour les
lotissements déjà viabilisés par exemple
et ensuite on a un palier important en
2025 puis 2028 donc je crois qu'on a
trouvé le bon point d'équilibré entre
ambition et progressivité
mais ça va être une petite révolution
dans la construction vous avez une autre
ambition que j'ai lu récemment qui est
celle de construire 250 mille logements
sociaux en deux ans alors j'ai regardé
un petit peu les chiffres et je voyais
quand deux en 2002 fin il y avait 380
mille logements qui avaient été
autorisées c'est une baisse quand même
substantielle de -14% de permis de
construire en moins par rapport à
l'année 2010 9 et moins de 90 mille
logements sociaux ont été agréés en 2020
enfin concrètement on a du mal à voir
comment vous êtes capable à l'heure
actuelle de respecter cet objectif
alors vous vous avez raison c'est un
très gros défi et c'est pas un défi que
je me lance tout seul c'est un défi que
nous allons relever avec beaucoup
d'acteurs c'est un très gros défi parce
que 90 mille logements sociaux l'année
dernière si on veut en faire deux cent
cinquante mille en deux ans ça veut dire
qu'il ya une marche importante à
franchir mais ça n'est pas que ma
volonté c'est aussi la volonté des
bailleurs sociaux de l'union sociale de
l'habitat qui regroupe tous les
bailleurs sociaux
c'est aussi la volonté de la fédération
française du bâtiment
c'est aussi l'affairé de la volonté des
promoteurs et ça devient progressivement
la volonté des élus parce que pour
discuter beaucoup avec des mères avec
des présidents présidents
d'agglomérations de communautés de
communes la prise de conscience est là
que on est en train de prendre un peu de
retard sur la construction construction
en général et construction de logements
sociaux
après tout ça est une question de projet
concret pour les construit comment quel
type de construction pour qui et ça doit
s'ancrer dans les débats locaux ça doit
s'ancrer dans une vision de l'urbanisme
2020 a été une année très particulière
évidemment avec le co vide mais aussi
avec des élections municipales qui ont
duré quatre mois entre le premier tour
et le deuxième tour plus le temps
d'élire les intercommunalités
maintenant que les nouvelles majorités
sont installés je pense que nous avons
des partenaires avec lesquels on pourra
le faire alors des partenaires mais cela
dit il y adhérer des réticences voire
des réactions on sait que vous êtes
n'est pas fort pas vous n'avez pas
forcément la cote auprès de quelques
maires du duvet du val de marne qui se
sont élevés contre contre vous sein d'un
collectif qui s'appelle un collectif
pour un urbanisme maîtrisé et qui met
qui met en jeu deux deux objectifs
contraires qui est l'un qui est de
préserver des espaces verts et en même
temps de construire plus de logements
sociaux
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez à ces
mères moi je ponds plusieurs choses la
première c'est que je défends le
logement social le logement social
partout et en particulier là où on en a
besoin
je ne fais qu'appliquer une loi qui est
une loi ancienne qui date de 2000 qui
est la loi dite sru avec son fameux
article 55 qui prévoit l'obligation de
construire des logements sociaux jusqu'à
25 % des logements dans les zones dites
tendues c'est à dire dans les endroits
où il y en a besoin et ça me paraît
normal de faire respecter cette loi et
c'est une loi de la république
je souhaite même qu'on la prolonge
puisque elle s'arrête en 2025 la
pression j'ai demandé à thierry repentin
qui est aussi un élu local de me faire
des propositions avec toutes les parties
prenantes donc la mf était bien sûr
représenté avec d'autres il ya plusieurs
options possibles soit en fait la
mécanique s'applique jusqu'à ce que on
arrive à 25 % soit on se redonne une
dizaine ou une quinzaine d'années ça
sera une proposition législative que le
gouvernement fera dans la loi 4 d mais
tout en ajoutant bien sûr l'étiage de
25% tout en restant sur l'étiage de 25%
essayons déjà de d'atteindre ses 25%
cette loi sru elle a permis de
construire 900 milles du 1,8 million de
logements sociaux construits depuis 2000
donc elle est utile et après ça n'est
pas inévitable d'avoir une contradiction
entre construire et aménager avec des
espaces verts et c'est ce que je réponds
aux maires du val de marne mais au maire
du désir line avec lesquels j'ai fait
une réunion de travail il ya une dizaine
de jours mais à tous les maires que je
vois lorsque je me déplace sur le
terrain on en a discuté avec françois
baroin j'étais chez lui à trois la
semaine dernière c'est une contradiction
qu'on peut dépasser on a une manière des
manières de construire dans lesquels on
trouve une forme de densité acceptable
avec aussi de la nature en ville des
espaces verts et des services et c'est
un besoin pour la population parce que
les mêmes qui nous disent que c'est
difficile d'avoir toujours plus de
logements sont aussi ceux pour lesquels
dont les enfants n'arrivent pas à se
loger sont aussi ceux qui veulent des
services de proximité et un accès à des
transports en commun donc cette équation
on peut la résoudre
et moi j'aimerais qu'on l'a résolve
ensemble politiquement
j'ai lancé une démarche qui s'appelle
habiter la france de demain parce que je
pense qu'il faut qu'on invente tous
ensemble comment est-ce qu'on veut vivre
en france demain vivre en france dans
les grandes villes dans le dans les
centres des grandes villes dans les
périphéries dans les villes moyennes
c'est évidemment pas la même chose dans
le val de marne et à dunkerque
comment comment on fait dans la ruralité
comment est ce qu'on construit cette
vision d'un nomadisme plus axée plus
accessible plus acceptable et plus
différenciés et donc c'est cette main
tendue que je propose aux élus et
d'ailleurs ces maires du val de marne
comme les autres je leur ai proposé un
rendez-vous d'accord donc mesure sur la
loi sru dans la loi cadre et il ya aussi
des critiques sur le manque de mixité
sociale est ce que là aussi il y aura
des mesures dans la loi de
décentralisation absolument pas ce que
c'est aussi important de construire des
logements sociaux que de savoir qui
habitent dans les logements sociaux et
comment est-ce qu'on en garantit une
vraie mixité sociale donc mixité des
classes sociales partout en france
la mixité sociale c'est l'un des
éléments très importants du vivre
ensemble
en fait ça fait vraiment partie de nos
principes républicains si je peux dire
et nous en avons besoin et le logement
social peut être un vecteur très
important pour y arriver je rappelle que
le logement social c'est pour tout le
monde c'est 70% des français qui sont
éligibles au logement social
mais lorsqu'on ne prend pas garde aux
attributions
on a tendance à créer des ghettos à
créer des endroits dans lesquels on
à des taux de pauvreté très important a
ajouté de la pauvreté à la pauvreté est
d'ailleurs créé une forme d'entre eux
soit de l'autre côté entre classes très
favorisés et ça ça peut se traiter si on
s'intéresse de beaucoup plus près aux
attributions de logements sociaux donc
dans la loi 4 d il y aura des
propositions législatives sur ce sujet
c'est une équipe pour vous deux excusez
moi que tu ne sais une façon pour vous
de lutter contre le séparatisme
absolument c'est l'autre volet de la
lutte contre le séparatisme
parce que plus on est mélangé plus les
classes sociales différentes vivent
ensemble plus le succès scolaire est au
rendez vous pour tous les enfants
vous avez d étude intéressante faite par
des chercheurs qui montre que la
diversité de niveau dans une classe est
en fait une chance non seulement pour
les élèves plus en difficulté mais aussi
pour les meilleurs élèves
donc cette mixité sociale c'est la base
de l'égalité des chances est dans cette
loi de décentralisation ce sera quel
type de mesures plusieurs choses d'abord
redéfinir qui sont les publics
prioritaires pour le logement social
aujourd'hui à 13 catégories c'est assez
compliqué et dire aussi que les
travailleurs dits travaillant essentiel
les travailleurs clé ceux qui font vivre
nos villes ont besoin d'être logés pas
trop loin de là où il travaille ensuite
responsabiliser plus les élus à la fois
l'échelle intercommunale et à l'échelle
communale et enfin travailler
différemment avec les bailleurs sociaux
puisque pour l'instant chaque
collectivité et l'état et action
logement ont chacun des quotas de
réservations de logements social et
finalement personne à la vision globale
donc retrouver les moyens de piloter
cette politique a un dernier mot sur ce
sujet yannick jadot au début du mois il
appelé à porter à 30% le seuil minimal
de logements sociaux dans les villes où
l'offre en matière d'habitat s'avèrent
insuffisantes
vous fermez la porte à cette idée mon
premier objectif c'est de faire
respecter une loi qui a presque eu faim
qui a plus de 20 ans qui dit 25% et on a
encore mille communes en france qui ne
respectent pas cette loi qu après
certaines communes puissent aller plus
loin c'est très bien il ya des communes
qui en plus de 25 % de logements sociaux
mais je crois que l'add-on égale libre
c'est 25%
on va parler de la loi de l'image bien
oui les associations de défense de
l'environnement alors vous accuse
d'avoir édulcoré les propositions de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas rester au
milieu du gué
alors que le conseil environnemental
social et le conseil économique social
et environnemental
le conseil pour la transition écologique
doutent de la capacité de la france de
respecter les engagements à l'horizon
2030 en termes de réduction des gaz à
effet de serre je ne crois pas il ya des
mesures fortes dans cette loi qui
d'ailleurs sont des mesures qui vont
être discutés parce que dans certains
cas et des obligations ou des
interdictions vraiment structurantes
si je prends mon domaine le domaine du
logement on va interdire à la location
les passoires thermiques donc les
logements avec une étiquette f ou g en
2028 ses 1,8 millions de logements
concernés et donc au contraire on va
avoir un défi important pour savoir
comment on accompagne ses 1,8 million de
propriétaires pour faire des travaux
dans les délais qu'est ce que vous allez
leur proposait justement ces
propriétaires qui voit cet objectif d'un
oeil circonspect
c'est ce que ça va coûter beaucoup
d'argent pour la rénover on va leur
proposer des aides améliorer on a déjà
mis en place ma prime rénove qui marche
très bien l'année dernière on louvre aux
propriétaires bailleurs cette année on
va leur proposer un accompagnement
améliorée je suis en train de finir de
conventionner avec les régions et les
intercommunalités pour qui un réseau de
guichets d'accompagnement de service
public sur l'efficacité et la rénovation
l'efficacité énergétique et la
rénovation
partout en france pour qu'il puisse y
avoir des points de conseil et puis on
va les aider à financer le reste à
charge quand il y a du reste à charge
privé en complément des aides publiques
comment fait-on pour financer j'ai
demandé à olivier sichel avec bruno le
maire de nous faire des propositions sur
ce sujet c'est c'est le directeur
général délégué de la caisse des dépôts
il nous rend là encore avec une task
force des propositions début mars pour
faire plus et plus fort sur les aides
l'accompagnement et le financement 10 et
de les aider au financement vous pensez
à quoi à des prêts à des taux
préférentiels de ckoi le secteur
bancaire est déjà en partie mobilisés
puisque souvent le reste à charge est
financé soit par du crédit immobilier
soit par de l'éco prêt à taux zéro soit
carrément part du crédit à la
consommation mais on peut aller plus
loin avec des offres intégrées qui
préfinance totalement éventuellement le
fait de jouer sur la baisse de la
facture compensée par un crédit ou
éventuellement même des propositions
plus innovants donc voilà j'attends ses
propositions autre question c'est que
vous avez les associations elles encore
on ont salué c'est vrai le nouveau
diagnostic de performance énergétique
plus visibles avec plus d'informations
il va intégrer le niveau d'émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et une estimation
de la facture annuelle d'énergie
cela dit pointait le fait que à partir
de 2023 donc les logements les plus
énergiques et l'énergie bord ceux qui
sont en catégorie g serait interdit à la
location mais ceci ne représente qu
environ 90 milles logements sur les 4,8
millions de passerelles énergétique est
ce que c'est pas un seuil trop trop
faible on interdit à la location toutes
les passoires thermiques d'ici à 2028
on commence au 1er janvier 2023 avec les
pires des pires s'est même pas tout
l'étiquette j'essaie vraiment le bas de
l'étiquette j'ai effectivement c'est 90
milles c'est très peu en 2025 c'est tout
l'étiquette j'ai peu à peu près 600
mille logements en 2028 ce sont les
étiquettes f et g
c'est ce que vous me disiez il ya trente
secondes en fait c'est ambitieux il faut
accompagner tous ces propriétaires donc
moi j'assume complètement de commencer
avec un petit volume de logements et de
monter progressivement le nombre de
logements qui sont interdits à la
location pour une raison extrêmement
simple
moi mon objectif ça n'est pas de sortir
des logements du marché locatif
par ailleurs je me bats pour qu'on
construise des logements pour que on
mobilise des logements vacants pour
qu'on transforme des bureaux logements
parce qu'on a besoin de plus de logement
mon objectif c'est que tous ces
propriétaires phase des travaux pour que
les locataires qui sont aujourd'hui
locataires de ce qu'on appelle des
passoires énergétiques c'est à dire des
en fait des logements très très mal
isolé qui chauffe autant l'extérieur que
l'intérieur quand il chauffe qui ont des
factures de dengue parfois plusieurs
milliers d'euros par an mais ça peut
aller à à 3000 4000 5000 euros tout en
ayant un confort absolument lamentable à
l'intérieur de chez eux pour que ces
locataires puissent vivre correctement
donc ça n'est pas une mesure punitive
l'idée c'est d'accompagner et pour
accompagner il
démarré avec un petit nombre de
logements est montée progressivement on
le fait entre 2023 et 2028 donc en fait
c'est très ambitieux mais qu'est ce qui
va se passer pour les locataires de ces
logements
si le propriétaire refuse de faire les
travaux ça veut dire qu'ils seront
expulsés de leur logement une aubade
joly en fait le logement ne sera plus
considérée comme d'essence qui veut dire
que le locataire peut mettre en demeure
le propriétaire de faire des travaux et
sinon se retourner vers le juge le juge
de proximité pour demander au
propriétaire de faire des travaux donc
c'est une voix de rocaille marche ça
sera aux locataires de faire la démarche
mais nous on aura une campagne
d'information très exhaustive avec les
collectivités bien sûr vis-à-vis de ces
propriétaires qui en général ne sont pas
de mauvaise foi qui parfois sont des
propriétaires modestes
donc il s'agit pas d'opposer les
locataires ou propriétaires mais d'aider
les propriétaires à changer on va
terminer avec quelques questions
politiques
julien alors quelques questions
politiques qui concernent par exemple la
la droite sénatoriale qui a présenté une
proposition de loi pour mieux lutter
contre contre les squats et que vous
n'avez pas soutenu pourquoi parce que je
moi je considère que le changement
législatif que nous avons fait dans la
loi qui s'appelle asap répond à la
difficulté le changement législatif que
nous avons fait c'est de dire tout squat
de résidence de domiciles de personnes
particulières peut être évacué sur
plainte
le propriétaire porte plainte à la
police la plainte est transmise au
préfet le préfet a 48 heures pour
décider et ensuite il mobilise la force
publique même en période de trêve
hivernale cette loi a été promulguée en
décembre on a écrit une circulaire avec
le garde des sceaux et le ministre de
l'intérieur en janvier
et donc il y a maintenant un régime
beaucoup plus protecteur des
propriétaires particuliers et ça n'est
que justice moi je suis comme tout le
monde je suis choqué des différentes
histoires et situations particulières
qu'on a pu voir ça a commencé avec ce
retraité à théoule sur mer jusqu'à sept
autres retraités à côté toulouse
donc je considère que pour tout ce qui
est squat de d'homicide
chez les particuliers la loi a changé
dans la bonne direction
donc elle pourra assurer à ses deux
propriétaires que là
la force de la justice passera beaucoup
plus rapidement mais c'est surtout que
ça ne passe plus par une procédure
judiciaire
ça passe par une procédure
administrative sous la responsabilité
des préfets
parce que la difficulté dans la période
actuelle c'est que dans certains cas il
faut saisir la justice et que c'est
forcément plus long ce que les
procédures judiciaires c'est plusieurs
mois parfois plus donc là on ne passe
plus par la procédure judiciaire
alors certains me demandaient de le
faire pour tout type de squat de tous
types de bâtiments y compris des
immeubles de bureau abandonné depuis
très longtemps et là je considère que la
proportionnalité nier plus parce que ça
n'est pas du tout la même chose dans une
situation où vous le squat a lieu chez
quelqu'un que ce soit une résidence
principale ou une résidence secondaire
ou une résidence occasionnels vous êtes
chez quelqu'un que dans un immeuble
administratif ou industriels
potentiellement désaffectée dans lequel
il s'est rien passé depuis dix ans la la
justice continue à passer donc ça reste
des procédures judiciaires et je trouve
qu'on a atteint le bon équilibre et que
le reste est un peu plus démagogiques
un dernier mot des régionales emmanuelle
wargon puisque vous avez déclaré que
vous étiez candidate en ile de france
dans le val de marne lui préciser moi ce
que le modem sera aux côtés de la
majorité présidentielle dans sa télé
absolument je serai avec laurent saint
martin dans l'aventuré des élections
régionales en ile-de-france nous
discutons avec nos partenaires le modem
mais aussi agir territoire de progrès et
les discussions sont plutôt bien engagée
après elles sont mais le modèle monaco
c'est parce que bell et lui écrase dit
le modem ils sont dans mon exécutif ils
ont voté 100 % de mes propositions tout
au long de mon mandat ça va être
difficile pour eux de faire campagne
contre moi il y aller
il ya des élus modem avec valérie
pécresse dans sa majorité maintenant le
bon m
en tant que mouvement politique a
déclaré soutenir être dans la majorité
présidentielle en ile de france comme
ailleurs et après ces élus auront à
décider et définir leurs propres lignes
mais le modem sera avec nous dans la
majorité présidentielle n'est pas
forcément leurs élus ce à chaque élu est
libre de ceux de s'autodéterminer et ses
fortes heureux je pense que c'est
important qu'on y aille parce qu'on a un
projet à proposer aux franciliens sur la
mobilité sur l'urbanisme sur
l'aménagement du territoire sur la lutte
contre les inégalités et voilà nous
porterons une voix qui j'espère
intéressera les franciliens merci pour
converser malades jargon à d'être venu
merci julien on regarde à une de la voix
du nord justement sur la situation
compliquée à dunkerque à une situation
qui alarme beaucoup de gens et
spécialement cette période où les
médecins disent attention c'est carnaval
ne fait pas n'importe quoi chez vous
voilà vous passez le message merci
julien merci madame et messieurs c'est
au club d'états et à la mutuelle
nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires
angie acteurs engagés dans la transition
zéro carbone des régions vous présente
le club des territoires
[Musique]